Speaker 1: All right, let's take a few more
calls from great people in the audience, you
can chat with me while chatting in a real
sense in audio visual or I guess, just audio
via discord at David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
Let's go.
Oh, I don't know.
How about Daniel from Alhambra?
Speaker 5: How are you, David?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Can you hear me?
I can hear you.
Speaker 5: All right.
Long time member, First-Time Caller.
Thank you.
I just wanted to point out, you know, the
Colin Powell death.
You know, it didn't take Republicans very
long to, you know, kind of get political with
his death.
You know, Republicans tend to, you know, after
a mass shooting or something like that, you
know, they they tend not to want to get too
political about right.
Speaker 1: This is not a time to publicize
tragedy, to politicize tragedy.
They say,
Speaker 5: right, you know, and same with
Alec Baldwin.
The unfortunate situation there.
I just thought it was kind of funny that,
you know, the Republican right wingers didn't
waste any time politicizing.
But I have a question for you.
What would it take?
What type of or what percentage of audience
membership would it take to get David Pakman
to have like a person, go out to rallies and
do kind of like, you know, on the spot coverage
of some of these events?
Speaker 1: That's a beautiful question.
That's a beautiful question.
I would love that.
I think that, you know, we talk about how
we estimate that somewhere between one half
and one percent of the total audience are
paid members.
I think if we were able to get to two percent,
we could hire a full time person to just go
to these wacky rallies, protests and political
events and do really, really good interviews
and that type of thing.
That would be a really exciting thing, actually.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I would love it.
I mean, I've been watching her, I've been
a member since your brother was on the show.
Wow.
And his name?
Yeah, so.
Challenge accepted audience.
If you're listening out there, let's get on
board and get someone out on the radio shows.
Absolutely.
Mr David, here,
Speaker 1: thank you very much.
I appreciate the call.
All right, thanks.
All right, very good.
Yeah, that's I love that idea.
That's a tremendous idea, actually